uh but why don't we get uh the view from
Labor uh no uh let's speak to the shadow
Northern Ireland secretary Peter Kyle
once again on the program uh good to see
you this morning Mr Kyle um just your
initial response uh to those CPI figures
I mean 10.1 a little bit of a drop but
people are still paying a huge amount
just to fill up the shopping basket
yes the the bottom line is that there
isn't a single person in this country
that will feel the difference in their
pocket because of this small Hall it is
still a historic high levels people who
haven't felt this for decades this kind
of impact it came just after finding out
just yesterday that the real terms fall
in people's income has also continued so
you've got higher inflation uh wages uh
are in real terms it's still in Decline
you know our economy is just being
mismanaged we need to make sure we can
get back to the basics we can start to
fix our Public Services uh because we
know that there is there are millions of
people seven and a half million people
waiting for treatment on the NHS these
people aren't being able to participate
in our economy in the right way we in
the labor party recognize that these
issues are all linked together we can't
fix the fundamental problems in our
economy until we fix the other issues we
have in our public services and
elsewhere uh so that's why we're
fighting so hard in these local
elections coming up and in the general
election of next year get the fresh
start that I've got our country really
needs and that's a fresh start with the
labor government sure okay but can you
be specific about where the government
is getting it so badly wrong in your
view in terms of macroeconomic policy
we'll just go back to last summer when
the labor party announced its cost of
living package fully funded by a
windfall tax uh independent economists
said that it would reduce inflation by
four percent the government chose
another pathway and of course we've seen
inflation Skyrocket since and the impact
and the corrosive impact that's had
right through our economy so all the way
through this we've had fully funded
fully costed measures which could have
actually got a grip on inflation but
also made sure that we suppressed the
the challenges that people have uh with
their cost of living and made sure that
we could have halted the decline in real
terms wages wages you know these are the
fundamentals of running an economy now
on top of that of course we want to make
sure that we're not just firefighting
for the moment we're investing into the
long term which is why our green
Prosperity fund would invest in
recapitalizing our economy creating
really good jobs right around the
countries from plumbers and Builders
right through to scientists and r d uh
and places that I'm speaking to you from
like Northern Island would benefit
hugely in terms of the investment in
really capitalizing on the the
scientific potential and the greeting
potential they have for green and
renewable industries that we can't just
solve the big challenges and the
long-term challenges our economy has we
can create new Industries and new export
opportunities you know these are the
things that fix the immediate challenge
that could have been created by the
conservative government but also creates
new opportunities right into the future
let's talk about Belfast Northern
Ireland and indeed the 25th anniversary
of the Good Friday agreement and there's
been an awful lot of praise and an awful
lot of Celebration about the agreement
that has lasted but we look at the
domestic political situation in Northern
Ireland no closer to a power sharing
agreement storment getting back to work
what is the way forward in all of this
because try as they might it doesn't
appear that anyone has a clue
well let's just look at the fundamental
achievement of the Good Friday agreement
because we can look at the challenges we
have now in the political ups and downs
since but the fundamental achievement of
the Good Friday agreement and that
remarkable generation that made it
happen 25 years ago it delivered peace
it ended armed civil conflict here
across the Northern Ireland so that has
endured and that has been a remarkable
success now until the broader political
challenges that you do raise what we
need to do in this generation is learn
because we have something that that
generation didn't have which is the
handbook on how you deliver for Northern
Ireland and we need to get back to some
of those those Essentials and that's why
here at Queen's University in Belfast
we've been learning for the last three
days about how they delivered the The
Good Friday agreements and I think some
of the things that they did back then we
could learn from so number one negotiate
uh get into the room uh create the
circumstances where people and
communities can come together and they
can actually make the kind of
concessions that an needed to deliver
process to build the relationships get
into the room and don't leave the room
persist secondly strengthen the
relationship between the UK and Irish
governments because when that happens
identity issues in Northern Ireland for
individuals and communities diminish and
then crucially and this is one of the
crucial things that's holding Northern
Ireland back right now in terms of
getting the dup back in is that the UK
government has to get back to the honest
broker rule because we've seen too many
times in recent years Prime Ministers
coming across here making promises to
Northern Ireland and breaking that
promise immediately we've also seen
legislation introduced into Westminster
which is opposed by all communities in
Northern Ireland but it's being forced
on Northern Ireland by Westminster and
until we get back to the role where
Westminster is an active partner for
Northern Ireland rather than an
assertive one which is disruptive we
simply can't get stolen up and running
again those those crucial institutions
and then have it up and running in an
enduring way
I wonder if we might just move on to the
Prime Minister Rishi sunak and the
allegation that he has failed to to
register on the on on the register of
Minister's interests you know some
fairly significant points what is your
view in all of this a simple mistake
perhaps
well the problem is that we can only
judge Richard sunac by the standards
that he has asked us to judge him and
that is on Integrity he when he on his
first day is becoming prime minister he
promised a government where Integrity
would be first and foremost now since
then we've seen him appointing people
like Gavin Williamson who only lasted a
few days in office because he failed the
Integrity test we've seen the Integrity
test being failed right across
government and now of course we've seen
it once again of course you know we
should see that got a fixed the same
thing for the very for the second time
uh since he's been in government we've
seen uh failure to declare now you know
so judged against his own standards that
he's asked us to judge him by he keeps
on repeatedly failing live up to the
defendant he promised to deliver these
will be the standards these will be the
standards that secure starma himself
failed to live up to when he breached
the MPS code of conduct when he didn't
declare the tickets to the football that
he got
but as prime minister as prime minister
he has a very particular promise he made
the public and it's not just the way
that he acts himself it's the way he
appoints people appointing people like
Gavin Williamson who didn't last very
long time
for something that your own party leader
did you do not meet the Integrity test
I I'll just repeat the point isn't it a
bit Rich for for labor to be attacking
the government for something you know
that secure Starman was found to breach
the MPS code of conduct over
all I'm doing is holding Rishi sunak to
the standards he asked us to hold him to
Rishi sunak made the promise and
repeatedly from the way that he has run
his government he appoints his ministers
and he personally behaves he fails to
live up to the standards he himself has
asked us to judge him by that is the
question that is that we're asking
ourselves right now now if he hadn't
made that promise I don't think the
conversation would have been the same as
it is today because we all know that
that we from time to time we do make
mistakes we know that some of these
things are arduous but Rishi sunak has a
very particular Financial background he
is a person with a complex Financial
background he is a person obviously
being able to meet the standards that he
promised the public that he would live
up to
before we let you go I just want to ask
one quick question and on what is
happening north of the Border in
Scotland
um and of course there are active police
investigations so we can't deal with the
specifics but a question that does keep
being raised is whether or not the new
first Minister Hamza Yusuf should now
suspend Nicholas sturgeon from the party
what's your view
well what we do know for a fact is that
the s p is imploding people in in
Scotland are being let down they're
being let down twice by a government in
Scotland that's imploding and a
government in Westminster that is not
delivering so of course what we're
trying to do is put together a a
credible alternative an inspiring
hopeful alternative with credible plans
to solve the challenges in public
services in Northern Ireland which
arrive the economy which is
underperforming because of the two
failed governments which are there to
serve the people of Northern over for
Scotland uh those are the things we're
trying to set out alternative to a
criminal investigation that's currently
underway into the SNP needs to follow
its course I think that Muhammad Yusuf
needs to get a grip on his party uh
because right now it is not capable of
serving the people of Scotland and
that's the thing that concerns Us in the
late party the most and our leader and
Assad AWA who is the most popular leader
in Scotland is is get is out there to
create to create the circumstances where
there can be an alternative that the
people in Scotland can have faith in
because right now the people of Scotland
really deserve to have a bit of faith in
someone and the labor party is there to
serve them at Peter curl great to have
you on the program we'll speak again
soon thanks for now